I'm constantly checking the time.
Sometimes for no real reason at all.
And I think it's because I usually feel
like I don't have enough time.
And I guess this is my attempt
to control it.
But this little habit has turned me
into someone that I don't really like.
So when I started
working with my first client,
who basically gave me
unlimited design freedom, I knew
I wanted to explore this idea of time
and is there any way to slow it down?
This video is sponsored
by SketchUp and Morpholio.
This feeling of being rushed.
It's a universal feeling,
especially in the digital age.
But if you think about it, it's
actually kind of ironic.
All of these tools are designed
to increase efficiency
so that we can have more time
and improve the quality of our lives.
But instead we're all just pushing
for more, more productivity,
more experiences, more excitement,
more things to see, more things to do.
F.O.M.O. (FEAR OF MISSING OUT)
But leisure in itself
has become a multi million dollar industry
that tries to keep us
constantly entertained, constantly wanting
more, and again making us feel like
we don't have enough time
There's a few moments in my life
where I felt the sensation
of being unplugged from the world.
There's a quality about these moments
that makes me want to slow down my pace,
willing myself to be lost and to be alone.
So when I started
designing the Orinda house (San Francisco, CA)
I tried to let these memories
guide the design.
In some ways,
I think this is kind of the perfect site.
You come here to disconnect from
the rest of the world at the same time.
The site does come with a few challenges.
Feels a little bit steeper than I thought
it was going to be.
So as you can see,
the hill is extremely steep.
It's got almost a 30 degree
slope and it's facing north.
So the hours of
daylight is actually quite limited
because it's blocked by this hill.
In fact, when we did a proper Sun study,
the only part of the site that got
lots of daylight throughout the day
is at the top of the hill right here.
There's also like a million protected
trees on the site.
Basically, anything over a six inch
diameter is a protected tree.
So I had to pick a spot that would require
the least amount of tree cutting.
We also have this 25 foot height limit.
So the lower we go down the site,
the shallower
we have to make the floor plate.
Otherwise, we have to corner to the hill,
which based on our Geotech report,
it will be possible,
but it will be a challenge
because the bedrock is very hard.
So this flat portion right here
seemed like the ideal location
for the building.
You get tons of daylight.
There's not a ton of trees around.
And with our concept of maximizing time,
this location seemed like a no brainer.
But the problem
was, how do we get all the way up here?
How do we get materials up here?
Building
a driveway will be very expensive,
and we'd have to cut down a lot of trees.
And the city of Orinda would not be happy.
The solution actually came from
an acquaintance.
Apparently, these little hillside
lifts are quite common in California
because there's so many steep
sites like this.
So the driveway and the garage,
they can stay right here
at the bottom of the hill.
And so you park your car right here
and you take your little hillside elevator
and that's how
you get to the house
as you slowly move up the lift.
You sit.
You look at the trees and you can also
see glimpses of the building
when you finally reach the top.
All you have is a platform
and a massive concrete wall on the side.
And when you touch the wall,
you're totally surprised
to find that it's warm and soft.
In the
summer of 2016, we traveled across Europe
to look at architecture
at the last leg of our trip.
We made our way to this little Swiss
village
called Head in State
to visit the home and studio.
Peter Zumthor, who happens to be one of
my favorite architects, nobody was there.
So technically
I guess we weren't actually visiting.
But regardless, the building was designed
by Peter Zumthor himself.
So I took like a million pictures.
I peeked through the windows and I touched
everything I could get my hands on.
Don't ask why.
It was just before we were about to leave.
As I was trying
to get my last few pictures,
I found a nice old window recessed
into a perfectly formed concrete.
But something was different
when I touched it.
I was shocked.
The concrete was soft and warm.
This hard
material had the texture of fabric.
I think the concrete must have been formed
using fabric
as a formwork,
and it conducted heat from the sunlight.
The only proof that I have of this
is this photo,
which doesn't even come close
to capturing this feeling.
But sometimes when I touch a soft linen,
maybe one that's been sitting out
in the sun for a long time,
it reminds me of this moment.
The problem is that
vision is the loudest of our senses,
and so by limiting our view of the house,
we start to pay
a little bit more attention
to our other senses.
You could hear the water in the distance,
and when you touch the wall,
you're surprised to feel
the strange texture under your fingertips.
You notice
your movements, the variation in the wall,
and maybe you start to slow down.
Once you turn the corner,
you enter into a garden.
And it's not just a garden,
it's a labyrinth.
And you have to take this meandering
path in order
to reach the entrance of the house.
And I'm sure over time
the family would build in shortcuts.
Maybe here and here and here.
But the main road
takes you on a long journey.
This very intentional complexity
of the path.
It creates a sense of mystery, curiosity.
Each new turn reveals a new moment,
a hidden corner,
a carefully framed vehicle,
or maybe a really soft moss
here, getting lost and then found.
That's the whole point.
That feeling of being blindly led
by your feet
elaborates, We're
actually used for meditation by priests
during the medieval times.
They're non-linear
and they can be disorienting,
but knowing that they'll eventually get
to the end.
These long walks were used
to reach a state of contemplation.
When you reach the end of the garden,
you land on a large stepping stone,
which marks the end of the labyrinth
and the beginning
of the house.
according to Juhani Pallasmaa,
images of water emphasize
architectural permanence
and concretize the passing of time.
The reflective surface of the water hides
depth and projects a second hidden world.
The double world activates our imagination
for the duality of past and future.
So in order to get this kind
of effect, the water needs to be
getting direct sunlight.
The light hits, the water bounces off,
and the refraction from the water
as projected
onto this concrete wall.
So after iterating
through a couple of different options,
we decided to place the pools
at the top of the site.
On the south end one reflecting pool
here and one accessible pool here.
And so we maximize the sunlight
and this refraction of the water
becomes a part of the entry experience.
So over here,
you can take a moment to pause.
We landscaped this area so that
the seeding becomes a part of the hill.
And instead of paving this area
with concrete, we continue the stone paths
so that this entire space
feels like one continuous garden.
So when you enter the house,
you enter into a hall with wood slats
on one side and a personalized concrete
wall on the other.
The patterns on the concrete
panels create rhythm as you enter.
The entryway is a transitional place,
and it's a place of movement.
And it's a place where outside becomes
inside.
Is your first few moments into the house
where you leave your keys, your coat,
where you leave your outside self behind
and you enter your home.
It's not a moment,
but it's an in-between moment.
And these are the moments
that usually get forgotten about.
These moments
make up only seconds in our days,
but added up they become hours and days.
And so by elevating this experience
with the light and texture,
we can make even these transitional
moments memorable.
As you
descend the stairs through this narrow
transitional space,
you experience expansion
for the first time.
You really see
the beautiful view over the hill,
the interconnected spaces of the house,
the reflection of the water on one side.
And for a brief moment you take a pause.
This isn't my typical process
for designing, but there was an object
that kept coming to my mind
as I was designing the building a sundial.
I think there's something really poetic
about it,
how the hands stay still while it
quietly witness
the fleeting hours and seasons.
But compared to a digital clock, it's
not dictated by the seconds of minutes.
And instead I feel a more gradual
passing of time.
Ha ha ha.
I think about the sun's journey
across the sky
and it reminds me of our connection
to the universe.
It makes me think about my existence
in the context of this vast space and time
as the sun
moves across the sky
from morning to evening.
I wanted the building to kind of dance
with the changing angles of the sunlight.
We tried a bunch of iterations of the roof
because it changed how the light
stretched into the living room
and into the office and into the kitchen.
Maybe this movement can even guide
some of the activity in the house.
But there's another moment in the house
where you experience light
in a totally different way,
and that will be underneath the pool
right here
where we get the refraction
through the water,
which is a totally different
quality of light.
This room actually drove
a lot of the relationships
between the spaces in the house.
I wanted the refraction to be a part
of the experience of the house
so that the living room and the kitchen
can borrow some of that refraction.
But because of the depth of the pool,
it was really hard to do that
without placing the relaxation room
on a completely different basement level,
which is why each of the spaces
stuck down a half storey.
This creates separate spaces
that still feel interconnected
and this works with the natural
topography of the site,
which gradually steps down
as we move towards the east.
Ha ha.
Time is a human made invention.
We create a time as a framework
to get organized
and measure progress
and make sense of our lives.
So maybe architecture can slow down
our perception of time.
Maybe it can make us pause
and maybe it can make us notice
the moments that usually go unnoticed.
You know, this whole craze
about the circadian rhythm,
it's really all about resetting
our systems back to the natural state
and realigning them
to the movement of the sun.
I think as architects, we often design
for the hours and the days in our lives,
but we often forget
about the seconds and minutes.
So how do we make these more granular
time intervals
more memorable in our lives?
I think those are some of the questions
that we're going to try to answer
as we progress the design.
We're still in the schematic design phase,
so things are still really conceptual
and there's still a lot of things
to figure out.
And in fact, since making this video,
the design
has actually changed quite a bit.
And because our business
is not just architecture,
it does take a little bit longer
for us to do things.
So please
be patient with the project updates.
But that's also one of the best parts
for me that we can explore
some of these concepts
a little bit more in depth.
If you're interested in some of the assets
that we're using for the visuals
like some of these watercolor people
will leave a link in the description.
Let me know in the comments.
What do you think about the project
and what other concepts do
you think we should explore?
And with that,
I'll see you guys in the next video.